hey I've got a really interesting story
for you there's a guy in Ohio really
rich guy named Leslie Wexner and he's
one of these rich guys that you might
not have heard of he's 81 years old now
he's worth somewhere between four and
six billion dollars and he's the
chairman and CEO of L brands which was
previously called something else but
it's the company that includes
Victoria's Secret Bath and Body Works
some very very major major companies and
this guy is super super wealthy I
actually have some friends that know him
he's a big philanthropist he happens to
be Jewish
and I have friends who have been
involved in some Jewish philanthropy
groups that Leslie Wexner is involved in
and everybody has known all along that
he's a Republican but he's more one of
these low tax pro-business Republicans
not an a social issues guy not as much
of an ideologue as someone that would be
sort of like Ana Ted Cruz wing of the
Republican Party we've now learned that
former President Barack Obama went to
Ohio to help Richard Cordray who's a
Democrat running for governor there and
while he was there he visited Leslie
Wexner and Wexner announced just after
this visit that he's leaving the
Republican Party saying quote I just
decided I'm no longer a Republican I'm
an independent I won't support this
nonsense in the Republican Party I've
been a Republican since college joined
the Young Republicans Club at Ohio State
he has been contacting Republican
elected officials and telling them that
he now considers himself an independent
that he is going to stop giving money to
Republicans in the way that he has been
doing for a very very long time so why
am I telling you this I'm not now
praising Leslie Wexner as some kind of
bastion of progressivism or saying this
is the guy what I'm pointing out is that
there is an entire wing of the
Republican Party more socially moderate
really focused on low tax pro-business
policy
who are seeing nothing in Trump that
resonates with them period to the point
that they're leaving the party and
Wexner has pointed this out he actually
told employees recently that he felt
quote dirty and ashamed when Donald
Trump equivocated around that
charlottesville white nationalist rally
where he said well there were very fine
people on both sides meaning the side of
those protesting against white supremacy
and the side of those who are white
supremacists and then he went on to say
quote I have to do something because the
leader of our country is behaving poorly
so from a strictly money point of view
we have a campaign finance system that's
a disaster that doesn't change if some
rich Republicans stop giving money to
Republican candidates but if this is the
system we have right now I'd rather
Leslie Wexner be so disaffected with the
Republican Party that he stops
contributing to Republican politicians
obviously secondly this is actually
something that at a certain point the
Republican Party these are the the Trump
coalition are going to have to figure
out whether they're gonna do anything to
change the direction that things are
going because it's not just Leslie
Wexner Seth Klarman is another major
Republican donor who's more new
england-based in our negative neck of
the woods he's mostly been giving money
to Democrats over over the last year
year and a half and if there is anything
that's going to make the Republican
Party pay attention to discontent in its
ranks you would hope that it's money
from major donors and you would hope
that it's starting to lose elections so
step one you got a vote in November
right you've got a vote because every
single loss that these Republicans take
is going to force them to reconsider
what it is that they're doing and then
of course people like Barack Obama very
influential powerful powerful speakers
who are also extraordinarily personable
and just good at relating to others
going and meeting in purse
with some of these big donors can
actually make a difference
I don't think Obama is gonna meet with
the Koch brothers and get them to
drastically change their donor patterns
but money and losing some elections will
get Republicans very quickly to
reconsider which direction it is that
they're going in